ein sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
entschuldigen sie bitte aus
Sicherheitsgründen müssen wir Sie
dringend bitten hier vor den Logen
wegzugehen bitte aus Sicherheitsgründen
bitten die Behörden dass sie die hier
sie stehen und nicht in der Loge sitzen
bitte
weggehen
bitte werden Sie so nett unsere Herren
werden sie noch einmal bitten und
auffordern danke
schön
bitte einen großen Applaus friends
United States Army Europe and Africa
Band
welcome einen wunderschönen guten Abend
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren zum 75
großen baldoffiziere hier in der Wiener
Hofburg good evening ladies and
gentlemen a pleasure to welcome you
annual 75th offic of the Austrian armed
for enjoy the next couple of minutes
freuen Sie sich jetzt meine Damen und
Herren auf den Einzug des ehrenkomitees
und unsere
erengäste
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Ladies
Gent Minister of national Defense meine
Damen und Herren unter der patronan
unserer Bundesministerin für
Landesverteidigung findet heute unser
Ball statt guten Abend Frau Tanner guten
Abend ver
Bundesminister
[Applaus]
der Veranstalter des Balles heute Abend
ist die Vereinigung alten Neustadt
dessen Präsident und gleichzeitig auch
Chef des Generalstabes general Rudolf
strriedinger wir herzlich
[Applaus]
begrüßen
wir freuen uns heute große musikalische
Delegationen aus den Vereinigten Staaten
begrüßen zu können den unserer gerade
Musik steit steht die United States Army
Europe and Africa Band in
vi es fres
seh und vielen Ehrengästen unter ihnen
auch die Botschaft in der USA Victoria
Regie Kennedy was Österreich und die USA
ganz besonders miteinander
verbindet good evening
Excellency was Österreich und die USA
ganz besonders miteinander verbindet
werden wir dann in der Mitternacht
showow musikalisch hervorheben ladies
and gentlemen meine Damen und
herrene Austrian National Anthem bitte
erheben sie sich für die österreichische
und europäische
[Musik]
Hymne
[Applaus]
[Musik]
jawohl Bravo vorem auf der europäische
Hymne ein Bravo an Europa ein Bravo an
austri ein Bravo
an danke schön eine spe bekommt nie
Applaus oder viel zu wenig Applaus finde
ich äh und das W jetzt am ändern darf
ich Sie kurz bitten dass Sie zu mir
herauskommen mit ihrem Partner bitte Sie
auch diese Damen und Herren meine Damen
und Herren stehen zerst schon
dreiviertel Stunde draßen gestanden
jetzt stehen sie noch um eine halbe
Stunde bis sie drank kommen äh niemand
ist bis jetzt ohmächtig geworden aber
das werden wir heute schon schaffen darf
ich Sie um ihren Namen bitten thereser
Striedinger woher kommen sie
wienerneustadt aus wienerneustadt ihr
Name Philip Teufel und welchen Rang
haben sie bereits welchen Rang bei der
österreische Armee haben sie schon eben
Fenrich fendr schaut aber sehr fesch aus
könnt man K mehr Glauben haben sie
einander beim Tanzen kennenelernt oder
kannten sie sich sonst schon so ja wir
haben uns beim Tanzen kennengelernt ist
guter Partner ja er ist seh gut beim
Tanzen ja was sollen sie jetzt auch
sagen nicht ist sie eine gute
Tanzpartnerin ja definitiv kann man
sagen ja ich habe immer die angewohnhit
bei solchen bäern zu fragen ob sie schon
einen Antrag machen wollen oder nicht
das habe ich leider einmal gemacht und
die dann wirklich
geheiratet das will ich Ihnen heute
ersparen danke schön aber
stellvertretend für die beiden nämlich
für alle bitte einen riesen Applaus für
die Damen und Herren des
eröffnungskomites danke
schön einen Applaus bitte auch das
müssen wir auch einmal an der Stelle
machen und ein Dankeschön an
Vizeleutnant Gerhard Springer der die
musikalische Einrichtung gemacht hat und
alles was sich hier choreografisch
bewegt meine Damen und Herren danke
schön Vizeleutnant
Springer das
ballmotto das sounds of music also sie
werden viele gedacht haben das ist jetzt
vielleicht ein Fehler auf uneren
Plakaten nein das ist Absicht nämlich
die Verbindung zu den Vereinigten
Staaten und eines der bekanntesten
Musikstücke in den Vereinigten Staaten
ist und bleibt nach wie vor das Sound
music das ist die wunderbare Geschichte
sie kennen alle und ich freue mich ganz
herzlich dass wir die
ururenkelin von Baron von Trapp heute
seinen Gast haben Christine von tra wo
sitzen Sie bitte please stand up please
welcome Christin V
TR grand grand
ofon V
[Applaus]
tr meine Damen jetzt geht's los jetzt
sehen Sie was diese beiden Riesen
Orchester gutes Miteinander drauf haben
unsere geradeemusik spielt nämlich jetzt
mit unseren Freunden von der United
States Army Europe und Africa Band
nichts anderes als aber das verrate ich
Ihnen noch nicht take a seat relax and
enjoy the
music
[Musik]
[Applaus]
every morning you
Gre
me small
and clean
and you look happy to
[Musik]
[Musik]
ven
GLM St
[Musik]
for
me
H
[Musik]
V Ladies Gent meine Damen und Herren
[Applaus]
ist
s United States Army Band und unsere
wunderbare Gard Musik thank danke schön
meine Damen Herren das war Sound of
[Applaus]
Music
[Musik]
lassen Sie mich ich bitte noch sagen
meine Damen und Herren dass die
schlagzeuggruppe die so fantastisch ihr
Solo vorhin hatte keine BE sind sondern
alles Rekruten der österreichischen
Armee alles junge Herren die das erst
lernen ich glaube das verdient noch
einmal einen riesigen
Applaus meine Damen und Herren Festgäste
Excellency ich es tut mir sehr leid dass
ich Ihnen meine schönste Seite zeigen
muss aber ich muss leider noch außen
moderieren i'm really sorry Excellency
es geht langsam aber sicher dem nächsten
Höhepunkt gegen denn jetzt kommen wir zu
dem auf das alle immer warten bei einem
Wiener Ball auch beim Ball der Offiziere
nämlich der fächerpolonese des jungdamen
und herrenkomitees gefolgt vom
sternenbannermsch von Karl Michael
Zierer im Anschluss erwarten wir unsere
Begrüßungsworte von General Rudolf
Striedinger und unserer
landesverteidigungsministerin Claudia
Tanner dann kommt es zum kaiserwalz und
dann zu den wichtigsten Worten aber
jetzt viel Vergnügen meine Damen und
Herren u für Sie das jungdamen und
jungherrenkomitee mit der
fächerponese viel
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Vergnügen
[Applaus]
meine Damen und Herren ich darf nun um
die Begrüßung durch den Chef des
Generalstabes general Rudolf Striedinger
bitten Ladies gentlemen the chief of the
General Staff general Rudolf
[Applaus]
strdinger
sehr geehrte Frau
Bundesministerin sehr geehrte geschätzte
Besucher des offiziersballs
2022 24 es ist für mich sowohl als
generalstopschef des österreichischen
Bundesheeres als auch in meiner Funktion
als Präsident der Vereinigung
altneustadt eine besondere Freude und
Auszeichnung sie alle zum 75 bal
deroffiziere 2024 begrüßen zu dürfen so
wird unser Ball durch die Anwesenheit
höchstrangiger Gäste ausgezeichnet und
ich versuche um h Verständnis dass ich
in anbetrachter Vielzahl der ehren und
Festgäste nur einige Persönlichkeiten
stellvertretend für sie alle persönlich
begrüßen werde an der Spitze unserer
Ehrengäste ist es mir eine besondere
Freude unsere Bundesministerin für
Landesverteidigung Magistra Claudia
Tanner begrüßen zu dürfen herzlich
willkommen
[Musik]
unitedates
austrioren
Exell in alter Verbundenheit begrüße ich
unseren Bundesminister für
Landesverteidigung außerdienst dr Werner
fastelabend ein herzliches Grüß Gott
unsere Militärbischof Exzellenz dr
Werner
freistter
es ist mir auch eine besondere Freude
dass der Obmann des
landesverteidigungsausschusses in
schöner Magister Oberstleutnant Volker
Reifenberger mit den whrsprechern der im
Nationalrat vertretenden Parteien David
stöckmüller und Robert Leimer anwesend
sind vielen
Dank meine sehrhrten Damen und
Herren schonen und die Zeit darf ich Sie
bitten den abschlussapplaus nach der
Begrüßung durchzuführen und ich darf
Ihnen noch vorstellen W heute noch an
Ehrengästen unter uns ist es freut mich
dass der Generalsekretär des
Außenministeriums Botschafter dr Nikolas
maschik hier ist genauso wie die
österreichische Botschafterin in den
Vereinigten Staaten
botschschafterin dr Petra Schneebauer es
ist mir eine besondere Freude ein
AC depy ass Secretary of Def East Asia
who in former times was deputy assist
Secretary of Defense for Europe and NATO
policy dr andre winitz ist under US für
alle Diensten Leiterinnen und Leiter des
Bundesministeriums für
Landesverteidigung und für alle
kommandantinnen und Kommandanten des
Bundesheeres darf ich stellvertretend
begrüßen
die Generaldirektorin präsidiale
sektionschefin Magistra Elisabeth KIS
den ausbildungschef und Kommandanten der
Landesverteidigungsakademie generalutn
Magister
erichitkowitz und den kabinettchef
unserer Bundesministerin Rom
maard der BAL
derofiziere present
[Musik]
bal
America general Daniel
hawkinson General of Vermont national
Major General Gregory
K
[Musik]
part
itary generalmagister Robert
Brieger Supreme Commander Europe
Commander US European Command general
christopheroli su Commander
Transformation general Christian B
Partners European
countri of of Italian Arm
forcesamineello und der Inspekteur Cyber
und Informationsraum der deutschen
Bundeswehr Vizeadmiral Dr Thomas
Daum wir haben aber auch Gäste aus
anderen Bundesministerien hier und es
freut mich besonders D aus dem
Gesundheitsminister die sektionchefin DR
Katharina Reich hier ist genauso wie aus
dem Außenministerium sektionschefin dr
Elisabeth Kornfeind und aus dem
Wirtschaftsministerium sektionchef
Magister Florian
Rauscher wir haben ebenfalls Vertreter
aus der Wissenschaft hier es freut mich
dass der Rektor der Montanuniversität
Leoben Universitätsprofessor Dr Peter
Moser genauso ist wie
Universitätsprofessor Dr Christian Hanus
von der Donau Universität kems auch die
Wirtschaft ist vertreten mit der
stellvertretenden Generaldirektorin der
Wirtschaftskammer Österreich Magistra
Mariana künel es freut mich auch dass
viele altneustädter hier sind und auch
Offiziere des Ruhestandes und
stellvertreten für Sie begrüße ich
meinen vorvorvorgänger general
Edmund
Entacher und abschließend möchte ich die
jüngsten Besucherinnen und Akteure des
heen B
speziell begrüßen die fenriche der
Militärakademie und die Studenten der
militärmedizin mit ihren bezauberten
Tanzpartnerinnen die mit der darbittung
des
sternenbannermarsches auch einen
besonderen Gruß an unsere Partner boten
haben und speziell für Sie und auch für
alle anderen darf ich um einen kräftigen
Applaus
[Applaus]
bitten
disu GU ab ladies and gentlem welcome to
Vienna welcome to the 204 offic B and
delighted that you and delations honor
us with presence
tonight
presenceentesent
[Musik]
forces
Atmos hofur PAL mot of
7 offic B
20 the famous
music
Focus
Event old austan naalic ge von tr
offic
willortunity
Listen sounds of music swing of
dan abschließend ist es mir eine
besonderes Anliegen mich bei allen V
jenen aufrichtig zu bedanken die mit
viel Engagement und hohem
Organisationsaufwand zum Gelingen dieses
herausragenden Balles beigetraen haben
und ich wünsche uns allen eine gute
Unterhaltung eine wunderbare und
rauschende Ballnacht mit unvergesslichen
Eindrücken und ich auf dich Frau
Bundesministerin nun um die Eröffnung
dieses fils ersuchen thank you very
much
Exzellenzen
Generäle Damen und Herren Offiziere
ehren und
Festgäste sehrte Damen und
Herren excellen
Generals distinguish ladies and
gentlem what a great
ceremony
great
so have
here Victor Kenny thank you so
[Applaus]
much
Speci
even
Sounds
mus
family verm
moreit
PR
family thank you so much
chrc
hipwin welcome
for special
prramership sehr Damen und Herren seit
dem letzten Ball hat sich sehr vieles
getan sehr vieles auch im Bundesheer
getan wir sind auf einer Mission
vorwärts unterwegs zu einer modernen
Armee zu werden und an dieser Stelle
möchte ich Ihnen allen danken Ihnen
allen die diesen Weg mit uns gemeinsam
gehen da steckt so viel an Arbeit
dahinter dieser heutige Abend das soll
aber geprägt sein vom feiern vom
miteinander dass wir gerade in Zeiten
wie diesen mehr denn je brauchen ich
wünsche Ihnen ich wünsche uns eine
rauschende Ballnacht ganz spezielle
interessante Begegnungen
unvergessliche Elemente und Momente und
ich freue mich diesen 75 baldoffiziere
zu
eröffnen
damit wird es spannend denn jetzt kommt
der Eröffnungswalzer bitte Applaus für
die jung Damen und die jungen
Herren unser
eröffnungsweizer
wie könnte es anders sein in diesem Haus
mit dem
Kaiserwalzer
[Musik]
alles Walzer ladies and gentlemen the
dance floor belongs to
you
[Musik]